whether you use it or not we all know
about siri the voice assistant that
comes along with all iphones despite the
almost universal familiarity with siri
not many people know about series
founders a common misconception is that
steve jobs created siri or that it was
created by the apple team but this is
not the case siri was founded by three
men named dan cutlass tom gruber and
adam share
and in april of 2010 apple paid 200
million dollars to acquire siri and
spearhead themselves into the voice
assistance space
so here's what happened to series
founders and where they are today
starting off with tom gruber tom is an
american computer scientist who was born
in 1959
i would say that tom was the brainiac of
the group as he was extremely
well-educated for his bachelor's tom
attended loyola university in new
orleans where he got a double major in
psychology and computer science he
graduated sama kumari in 1981 which is
the highest latin honors indicating that
he was part of the top five percent of
his graduating class after completing
his bachelor's tom turned around and
attended the university of massachusetts
amherst where he majored in computer and
information science tom was actually
working on something similar to siri way
back in the 1980s for his master's
research tom developed a communication
assistant for individuals with severe
physical disabilities anyway tom
graduated with his masters in 1994 and
tom would find himself at the university
of massachusetts amherst once again for
his phd his doctoral paper was called
the acquisition of strategic knowledge
and it was about how computer assistance
could acquire strategic knowledge from
experts as you can see tom was on this
computer assistant slash aipath from
very early on but he still had a very
long way to go before siri after he got
his phd in 1988 dom became a research
associate at the knowledge systems
laboratory at stanford for six years
the three main research projects he
worked on at stanford include how things
work shade and knowledge sharing
technology at this point tom was 35
years old and he had spent basically his
entire life in academia in 1994 he
decided to finally change this by
getting a job at enterprise integration
technologies as senior project leader
that same year tom created a free
program called hyper mail that helped
users create email archives kevin hughes
revised and rewrote tom's code before
the release and hypermail is actually
still used to this day by most email
clients on unix and linux in 1995 tom
left his project leader job and created
his own company called introspect
software the company specializes in
helping commercial customers with
collaborative knowledge management given
how niche of a market they targeted the
company never blew up into the billions
or anything but it does seem like
they're still around and employed
between 50 and 100 people tom didn't
join syria up until january of 2008 when
the company completed its first private
funding round the initial goal of the
project was to create a conversational
medium that gave users access to all the
information in the world despite its
ambitious goal siri was more or less
just a backburner project throughout the
1990s and early 2000s one of the other
co-founders adam chair says that it
wasn't until the launch of the iphone
that they really knew where to take siri
in the few years following the launch of
the iphone the trio worked on turning
the research project into an app and in
february of 2010 siri was launched as an
app on the apple app store at the time
the trio was planning to expand the app
to android and blackberry when they
randomly got a call from steve jobs just
two weeks after the launch steve invited
a three to his house where he made his
acquisition intentions clear while the
trio was extremely happy to meet with
steve and felt that their efforts were
finally validated the trio didn't have
any plans of actually selling the app so
they would decline steve's offer but
steve didn't take no for an answer he
kept in touch with the trio over the
next few months and eventually convinced
them that he was the guy who could take
siri to the next level steve promised
that siri wouldn't just be a tiny
feature but rather an integral part of
many apple devices i think steve was
being sincere with this promise as siri
did become a major part of apple but
unfortunately it wasn't exactly how the
founders envisioned it the problem was
that apple placed a major emphasis on
search as opposed to improving series
conversational abilities as the founders
wanted this was one of the main reasons
that google and amazon were able to
quickly make up ground and arguably
overtake apple within the voice
assistance space despite this rather
bittersweet result tom stuck around at
apple for quite a bit of time tom served
as the head of series advanced
development group up until july 2018
at that point he was nearly 60 years old
and had made plenty of money from siri
so he basically just retired and has
been focusing on photography and ocean
conservation he has been involved in a
couple of tech projects since his
departure but it looks like his favorite
endeavor is a non-profit called
humanistic ai the company focuses on
encouraging collaboration between humans
and artificial intelligence as opposed
to replacing humans with ai
but that's pretty much it for tom gruber
moving on to adam cher we have the
father of siri adam was born in 1966 or
1967 presumably in sharon massachusetts
where he attended sharon high school
after graduating from high school in
1994 adam attended brandeis university
where he majored in computer science
following his bachelor's adam scored a
job as a computer scientist at sri
international's artificial intelligence
center adam would return to university
just a couple of years later though and
earn a master's in computer science and
artificial intelligence from ucla in
1993.
after getting his masters adam returned
to sri international and got to work on
the first prototype of siri
adam says that as soon as he started
working with computers in the early
1990s he knew that figuring out ways to
interact with machines in a more natural
way was the future
over the next several years adam ended
up creating dozens of siri prototypes
but the biggest catalyst for siri didn't
come until 2003. in 2003 darpa gave sri
international funding to build a virtual
assistant darpa was hoping that this
virtual assistant could be used by
military commanders and though that
never quite panned out darpa's funding
did allow sri to employ 500 engineers to
work on siri for five years after
funding from darpa started to dry up in
2008 adam secured 8.5 million from
private investors and this is when dan
and tom would get involved this
investment allowed them to create the
siri app and sell their company to steve
jobs at the same time adam also started
working on some other startups in 2007
he co-founded change.org which is an
extremely popular petitioning website
with over 400 million users that same
year adam also co-founded sentient
technologies which is more of a
background ai company one of their most
notable works includes collaborating
with mit to create an ai-powered blood
pressure tool that could predict the
likelihood of sepsis in icu patients
anyway jumping forward to after the
acquisition adam was made the director
of engineering at apple
adam didn't stick around for very long
after steve jobs death though
disappointed in the direction of siri
adam left apple in september of 2012 and
it created a new virtual assistant
startup with siri's other founder dan
given their history with siri it wasn't
too difficult to get a crap ton of money
from investors and get their startup
vive labs off the ground
in contrast to siri we focused on
creating an open platform assistant that
could support external plugins and guess
what in october of 2016 adam and dan
would sell bblabs none other than
samsung for 215 million dollars
samsung would eventually implement this
technology into their bixby virtual
assistant so not only did adam and dan
sell a company to apple but they also
sold the company to samsung truly quite
impressive and ironic at the same time
adam stuck around at samsung for a
decent amount of time but he left
samsung as well in july of 2020. since
then adam has taken on a bunch of
advisor roles at a variety of companies
including riva health auto.ai halt labs
evolve technologies brilliant labs and
the brandeis university science advisory
council but that's pretty much it for
adam and that brings us to siri's last
co-founder dan kittles
unfortunately dan is the least known of
the three founders and there's very
little information about him online
but this doesn't mean that dan wasn't an
integral part of siri dan is a norwegian
entrepreneur who spent most of his
childhood in norway it wasn't until
college that dan came to america
dan attended indiana university
bloomington where he majored in
economics after he graduated in 1999
though dan returned to norway where he
worked as a barista at an upscale pub
called lectern dan did eventually pursue
an nba but this time he decided to stay
in norway opting to attend bi norwegian
business school after graduation dan
eventually found himself working at the
telenor mobile norway's national
telecommunications business as the vice
president he stayed there until 2002
when he jumped over to motorola as
general manager for about five years
after motorola dan became an
entrepreneur in residence at the
stanford research institute in june of
2007
this is where he would get introduced
adam and tom and the rest is history fun
fact dan was actually the one that came
up with the name siri which translates
to beautiful woman who will lead you to
victory norwegian
anyway after the acquisition dan was the
first to openly express his discontent
in the direction of siri he said quote
i'm not happy with where it is today
considering the lead we had when we
launched it they should be way ahead by
now
i don't think you'd be surprised to hear
that dan was the first to leave apple in
october of 2011 right after steve job's
death at first dan was planning on
simply retiring and writing a novel
but after adam quit apple as well the
duo would end up founding vive labs the
following september
after samsung acquired beef labs dan
became a vice president at samsung but
once again he was the first leave
samsung as well in june of 2019
this time dan did take a little over a
year off but soon enough he would
co-found another company called riba
health in november of 2020. riva health
is looking to allow users to measure
their blood pressure in a clinically
approved way using smartphones it's
still in the very early stages so we'll
have to see how it goes but dan believes
that riva health could be a key step in
identifying and preventing heart disease
early on
and that's what happened to series
founders which virtual assistant do you
think is the best comment that down
below
also drop a like if you think series
founders are underrated and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm ari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]
you